direction vénissieux dans le rhône
maintenant c'est toujours spectaculaire
un peu triste aussi une tour de 15
étages a été démolie à l'explosif
aujourd'hui les tranches de vie qui
partent en fumée
c'est aussi la poursuite d'un vaste plan
de rénovation qui touche la france toute
entière virginie fiche philippe avec dix
mille mètres cubes de béton redevenu
poussière en une fraction de seconde la
tour 42 a rendu son dernier souffle
effacée du paysage qu'elle dominait
depuis plus de 30 ans des gens s'en sont
nés se sont mariés
c'est toujours un tassement 95
ouais ça va être ses cochons toujours à
celle qu'on a c'est mieux s'il faut un
brasero quartier afin de reconstruire
je pense que ce qu'il faut pour la mère
l'avenir c'est un programme de 120
logements en maison individuelle et
petits immeubles collectifs un habitat
rénové et plus attractif qui semble
ramener un peu de quiétude dans ses
quartiers à la réputation difficile
elle a réalisé un premier test à
l'arrière à la place de lattre 67 qui
était démolie et trois ans et a priori
les premiers retours qu'on a sont assez
positifs les le produit logement en
petits collectifs vais plutôt mieux que
ses tours d'ici 2006 une voisine de la
tour 42 subira le même sort sur les
graves à vénissieux construit peu à peu
son défi changé de visage pour changer
la vie